Hello I'm Jonathan Worth from the
Connected Academy.
Talking Pictures:Critical Engagement with Visual Storytelling is brought to you in
association with the World Press Photo Foundation.
Today we're going to talk about a project that documents the families of people who are missing.
People who have been forcibly disappeared during a civil war that
lasted over an extended period of time. Its why we asked you to think about how you
might go about telling the story of something that isn't there in
preparation for this session.
You'll hear from a photographer and journalist who
spent multiple years making an oral
history and visual document of people
who've lost family members to a war in
the Middle East, that began over 40 years
ago, and probably thousands of miles away
from where you are now.
You might well question what the relevance of that is to you, but there are themes common to
all storytelling and so what we have
here is a particular case study, wherein
a lot of these themes crop up. So as a
way to think about some of those themes
and make them into jumping-off points
for us to discuss in a connected notes
let me ask you: What are the different
vulnerabilities that you hear in this conversation?
With whom do the duties of care lie?
What are the responsibilities of both the photographer?
And the photographed?
And as audience what are our responsibilities?
and finally, do images function as evidence?
it sounds like an obvious one, but ask yourselves again, do images function as evidence?
And how do images and their meaning change over time?
So let me describe it again differently, with those questions as a frame:
You're about to listen to a female, Lebanese photographer who only ever knew war growing up.
She became a photo editor,
but burnt-out, through the effects of
looking at an unending stream of images
of war and its effects on her own people.
You'll hear how she made peace with
photography again and then when the war
ended in a journalist left, their work
done, she began to make her body of work.
It's a series of portraits of the people
like herself who were left behind.
There are three things I find particularly
fascinating about this conversation: what
is it that she's making? Her approach to
making it, and thirdly, what will 'it" come
to mean?
Each of her subjects is kind of an
archivist in a way carefully shepherding
the evidence of their loved ones. Those
scant everyday belongings of the people
who didn't come back; a toothpaste tube, a
pack of cigarettes, a poster. Each one a
touchstone to the past and providing
another testament to their loved one.
And the old age of these people reminds us that, one can imagine a time, not so far
from now, after the cigarettes have
disintegrated, and the houses have been
cleared. When all that will remain of
these people's stories will be Dalia's
project; "The Missing".
And you've got
Benjamin Chesterton, a male English,
ex-radio producer who doesn't speak Arabic and who has to produce two different
versions of her project for radio and
web audiences, over a very short space of
time with all is inherent technical
difficulties. And you're going to hear
from the people whose stories they're
both trying to tell and just what that
process was like, and is like, for them to
go through.
Don't forget to share your notes in the platform comment on other people's notes
take time to pause,
reflect, review sections, go back through
the stuff you're not sure about,
dig around in those networked class notes,
that's where the real value is -
in the conversation not the content,
and try to be supportive of the people who can't get into a room with other learners.
Merhaba.
My name is Dalia Khamissy and I'm a photographer based in Beirut, Lebanon.
Since 2010 I've been working on the
estimated 17,000 missing and forcibly
disappeared from the 1975 to 1990  Lebanese Civil War.
The victims were from different political and religious backgrounds they came from all parts of
Lebanon and they were of all ages. The
kidnappers did not differentiate
between men or women at that time
But the missing was not exactly the first
project I did on the aftermath of wars
that I lived.
In the summer of 2006 I witnessed the terrible Israeli aggression on Lebanon as I was working
for the Associated Press and its office
in Beirut as a photo editor.
A year later I went to the south of Lebanon the area that suffered the most
during the 20o6 war and it was heavily bombarded. I had seen those images during
the 2006 war but I had not seen them through my eyes since then. That day I had my camera with me
I entered homes that were destroyed and abandoned.
What really shocked me was how much the private homes of people, had become public.
Anyone could enter them because there were no more doors anymore
and obviously no more inhabitants.
On the floors lay clothes of those who lived there,
sometimes photograph belongings
keys.
Even though there were no people to photograph
I said that those houses told the stories of their owners.
Those spaces reminded me of how much my life turned into public during the war.
I have no personal life back then. My
private one was like, dead.
As a photo editor my phone was ringing constantly, starting as early as 5 or 6 am
Sometimes, until hours after midnight.
My computer screen was full of messages
from everybody requesting photographs
from all AP's offices, like, all over the world.
I had to stare at photographs on the computer screen everyday.
For 34 days.
Images of the injured, the dead, the
destruction, people crying the death of
their loved ones,
heartbreaking photographs of people I
related to. The war had forcibly turned
my life from private to a public one, the
same as for those spaces.
So I took photographs of few houses and
I then formed a series of photographs
that I titles  "Abandon Spaces".
I only shot that over few days, but I felt it
was my way of reconciling with
photography.
After that project I started working on the Lebanese issues
especially those related to women's rights,
until I decided to start researching the
subject of the missing
[Jonathan] Saree Makdisi,  Professor of English and Com parative Literature at the University of California Los Angeles.
[Saree] The Lebanese civil war began in 1975 and ended in 1990.
It was a war over the distribution
of power among and between different
sectarian groups in the country or
really, more specifically, the
distribution of power among the elites
of different sectarian groups.
The principal axis of tension in the war was between those who wanted to maintain the
older system of Maronite hegemony (the
privileged Maronite Catholic elites) and
those who wanted to make the political
system more representative of, and
accountable to, the population of the
entire country. So although it's often
depicted as a religious war or war over
religion or even a war between religious
communities or sects, it really was a
struggle over the distribution of power.
Despite this fighting and displacements
of population did often blend into
tensions between different sectarian
communities and at times degenerated
into blind, inter-communal violence. On
top of the killed and injured there were
thousands of kidnappings it took place
during the war the kidnappings were
often done on the basis of one's
communal or religious identity because
Lebanese identity documents officially
list your religion. If you're caught by
the wrong kind of party and you have the
wrong kind of id, you could be in
trouble and that happened to a lot of
people during the war. The kidnappings
were sometimes for ransom,
sometimes for murder, sometimes for
execution and torture, sometimes for
reprisal, sometimes revenge and sometimes
for personal vendettas. So it's not clear
necessarily why somebody's kidnapped
very often people would disappear and
that would be that. Nobody would know
what happens to them. Everybody knows
somebody who was kidnapped I personally
know a neighbor of ours who was
kidnapped and then held for a few days
and then released I have a relative who
was kidnapped and released I think the
same day
and one of my closest childhood friends
was kidnapped with his parents and never
heard from again. And of course there's a
big difference between killed and
wounded and those who had disappeared
because killed or wounded I mean awful
is that is of course for the people
themselves and for their families and
friends and so forth at least you know
what happened whereas people who dis
disappear you don't know what happens to
them so there's no closure there's no
resolution for the trauma. It's important
to point out that those responsible for
the kidnappings for the most part remain
very close to power in Lebanon given the
country's amnesty law right after the
war. They've been absolved of guilt and
responsibility.The fates of those that
disappeared in the war has never been
resolved and certainly nobody's been
held accountable for the crimes they
committed.
[Dalia] During the war of 2006 many
international photographers and
journalists came to Lebanon to cover the
events. The country was full of foreign
press. The war lasted for 34 days and the
press was doing superb work, like a
super work covering the direct events,
the bombardment, its horrors, something I could
have never done.W hen the ceasefire was
agreed on in August 14 the media kept
documenting the direct aftermath for a
few weeks before the country was empty
again and the people who were left
behind were left to suffer with their
own new realities. That was my case too,
all the international photographers had
left they all had them month off to
rest but I was the one who had to stay
behind and the country that was destroyed was the one I lived in. It was like
the horror never ended. This is the same
case for the Civil War and all the wars,
conflict, clashes that happened since I
was born. The media leaves when those end,
so through my photographs I try to tell
the stories of people who are left
behind. Those who stories do not specifically interest the mainstream media.
The issue of the missing and kidnapped haven't been covered much lately,
so in my project I wanted to dig deeper in the story,
I met Aida and Lena Geadah at the tent
during a gathering for Odette Salem
who was killed when a car hit her. Odette was the mother of two young men and
his sister her son and her daughter were
kidnapped in the 80s. The families were
all devastated, it was yet another mother
who had died before receiving any
information on the fate of her children.
The day of the funeral her sister allowed us to visit Odette's home for few minutes as I
went from one room to another, her home
looked as if it was untouched for
decades. Inside her daughter's closet
hang a life-size poster of a male model.
On the bottom of the closet next to shoe
boxes lay some old dolls and on the wall
was hanging a black-and-white poster of
the Eagles. Those are items that people
throw away daily while they have no
value for us they act as one of the main
evidence for the one-time presence of
the missing person.
The photographs of the belonging gave much more depth to the project
Three years later in 2012 I called Lina - after as she and her
mother would allow me to take their
photographs and tell their story.
[arabic  to be translated]
[Dalia] Through my photographs I try to tell the stories of people who are left behind
those who's stories did not specifically
interest the mainstream media.
The issue of the missing and kidnapped haven't been covered much lately. So in my project I
wanted to dig deeper in the story, to, to
learn more about the different
narratives behind the missing and the
kidnapped. At the beginning I
photographed portraits for example, of
the families, then I learned about the
belongings they kept of the victims.  With
each family a different story the same
pain of course but a different story and
details.
A fter a month or two I got in touch with
Benjamin Chesterton from DuckRabbit.
We emailed back and forth and he was
interested in my way of photography.
I told him about the project of the
missing and she was later decided to
come to Beirut and work with me on that
project for the  BBC.
For three days Benjamin and I met mothers of victims of enforced disappearances
we met with NGO people, MPs,  ex-militia
members, women telling about the last
time they saw their children, their
husbands, they talked about their
continuous struggle and their only wish
to know the fate of their loved ones.
[Benjamin] Most of the interviews with the families were conducted in their mother tongue
and obviously Dalia would conduct those
interviews and I would assist with
really helping her to shape them.
In a sense, in that situations its hardest for her
because she's got to bring a
stranger into a situation is very
painful for those women and if you read
the interviews that she conducted with
them for this project they talked about
each time how the wind is opened up and
that is an extremely difficult thing for
anybody to do repeatedly in front of
journalists or anyone.
[Dalia] Aida's husband Kamal, was kidnapped in 1985 along with his nephew as
they were coming back from their work
they never heard of them again.
So along with Amal the mother of my friend I visited them at home.
Aida refused to be photographed even after Amal insisted. I looked for the best place
to take the photograph of Lena.
There were two chairs that were placed on each side of a small table
and on the wall behind them a painting was hanging.
Aida brought a framed portrait of her
husband from the 80s and placed it on the table
along with his pipe
[Aida] [Arabic to be translated]
[Arabic to be translated]
[Dalia} As I move the sofa facing the two seats and stood behind it to have more space and distance
Aida suddenly sat on the seat and told me to take the photograph.
We were all shocked a man Lina and
myself.
She had resisted being photographed for
over an hour while we were having tea
earlier so I just clicked through frames
and then her daughter said for the
portrait after her.
[Benjamin] This is what I love
about this image. There's a huge amount of respect.
Dalia's not trying, she's not
trying too hard here, and it's it's subtle and
it's poetic.
So we talked about the idea of beauty
she does, and it's a beautiful image. Its a throughtful image.
[Dalia] So anyway when I developed the films and scanned them, I Aida's  photograph to the Geadahs by email.
Both of them thought that the photograph looked very empty.
Amal and her daughter on the other side
thought it was beautiful and represented
her situation and the emptiness in her
life.
I explained by email also that this
was exactly what I was aiming at the
empty chair that was supposed to be
occupied by the husband, had he not been
kidnapped. Instead a photograph of him
from the 80s sitting on the table. As
if time froze for him after he was kidnapped.
In the photograph he's smiling
when life was better for the family and
by coincidence he was looking at his
wife Aida, who has aged and was looking at me with sad eyes
thirty years after his kidnapping.
[Aida] [Arabic to be translated]
[Arabic to be translated]
[Benjamin] So there's nothing to be pitied there.
That is a strength and a defiance
and an anger mixed with a little bit of hope,
that each day is getting spuffed-out.
So it's always like a privilege and a
pleasure to be in such a place as a
welcome guest, very much as a welcome
guest.But professionally you're thinking
what do I need? And really, that welcome
and that trust it's only worth it for
them if you do a good job. If you tell
their story properly. It's only worth the
pain that they have to go through when
they open themselves up, if you meet that
with a professionalism and a
determination to get it right.
[Arabic]
[Dalia] I believe that taking the time to get to know people.
Going back again and again and again and showing that you care about them and their
problems. And that we're not only here to
photograph them and leave, but that we
are really trying to make a change and
that their cause has become ours.
This  makes people open up and trust us and let us into their lives.
The families tell the stories of the missing loved ones, they show their belongings that they had
guarded for decades. They share all the
details and evidence they had collected
throughout the years. I had understood
the value of those belongings and
photographed them as precious relics.
Each item alone.
[Benjamin] I was thinking about what I wanted to say particularly in relation to you as the audience looking at a photo
and how you might respond to that photo
And the thing that I wanted to tell you was that, the danger of the
photo is that it holds someone in time
in moment. It kind of says, this is this
is it, right? And life is not like that,
because it's much more complex and
sometimes we need Dalia to have sat
down with the women and just hear what
they think and it kind of takes away a
lot of the formality of what you're
seeing and your feelings about what
you're seeing. In fact what I would say
is her interview with the women, in many
ways, is actually more humanising than
the photograph itself and that's
something really interesting to reflect on
[Jonathan] Thank you everyone.
There are lesson here, not only within the stories contained within The Missing
but there are lessons for us on how visual storytelling is done,
what those dynamics are in that process and pointers as to how
we can become more sophisticated as both media producers and media consumers.
There is a tension in photography and
there always has been, an uneven
distribution of power. A necessary
vulnerability. The basic premise is the
same Photography enables us to see the
world through the eyes and the lens of
someone else, and there's an intimacy in
that. But when a person brings a camera
or a smartphone up to their eye they,
there is immediately the photographer
and the photographed, and there will be
the audience or the viewer at some point
and the most powerful stakeholder in
those three-way relationships is almost
never the subject. The subject has to
agree to be vulnerable and not just once
not just at the point of the shutter
release, that photograph may never be
seen within the context that it was
actually taken. The chances are it will
live on in many different contexts even
simultaneously and its meaning might
well shift with each audience and each
time the subject will be vulnerable again!
Its why these class interviews are
set up the way they are, between a
photographer, a subject and the audience.
It's to explore that tension and then,
its for us to reflect on our relationships
with the world when we bring the camera
to our eye and make the world our
subject. And listening to Dalia's
conversation one of the first things
that's apparent is that telling someone
else's story is a speculative endeavor.
I mean Dalia and Benjamin ask
permission of their subjects in the full
knowledge that they might well, and do
sometimes, say no. Dalia the talks of
people agreeing to have their
photographs made years after she's first
asked them and we begin to get a sense
of the negotiation that takes place
between the subject and the photographer
and the importance of the trust in that
relationship.
I said in the introduction that what Dalia's work will come to mean is interesting.
But that applies to all our images it is
difficult if not impossible for us to
know what our images will come to mean in future contexts, what their values might
be and to whom, which is problematic when we've negotiated or built a trust
relationship with our subjects. What did
we promise? What is their understanding?
What exactly did they give their consent
for? Have we been transparent and honest
about what we can and can't promise?
Because when the subject appears as an
image they're going to stand alone and
we can't possibly predict what the many
possible feedback loops (consequences) for that subject might be.
We all have a right to carry a camera but does that automatically confer the right to
photograph other people? And if so then
it's interesting to consider what the
circumstances might be where we would
feel justified in doing so, if say it
made the subject feel uncomfortable
distressed or scared, to go to the very
edge of where we feel uncomfortable
about dealing with that as photographers.
This is the thing that I love about Dalia's work, we don't know where it will lead
but we know it's built on foundation of her asking those tough questions
on a subject by subject basis,
exposing her own limitations and
vulnerabilities. And we know that each
image is a testament to that rigour and
integrity. It means that with each new
layer of the evolving project from
places, to artifacts, to portraits, oral
testimonies, to Facebook and to an
Instagram feed the project grows as more
and more people buy into the process that
Dahlia has set out.
So now is the time here in this session for you to put down
your own moral markers. To take a
metacognitive view,
to step back and look at your own practice from a distance, and to spell out your best, practice your code of ethics.
You can also now access the deep dive materials including the
extended interviews and our interview
with World Press Photo winner Rena Efendi
in that she reflects on all five of the
course's key questions with reference to
her work, and in particular two examples
where she's telling the stories of
things that are no longer there.
Once again, don't forget to dig around in the class notes. Investigate the hotspots.
See why particular parts of the conversation of being responded to and by whom.
Reach out and connect with people, and support those who can't get into a room full of fellow students
Once you've had your fill of that, revisit your four corners image
and don't forget to submit it in time for it to be included in our webinar review.
I'm Jonathan Worth and you can connect with me
via Twitter @Jonathan_Worth
Hopefully I'm floating around right now in the Twittersphere as you listen to this.
Thanks very much.